ich habe keinen ton
hmm
sie wird 65 jahre im zuge der heutigen
verhandlungen die in einer sachlichen
atmosphäre verlaufen sind haben wir uns
ständig und verständlich die
bilateralen beziehungen besprochen und
blieb perspektive deren entwicklung
besonders viel aufmerksamkeit widmen wir
den problemen der internationalen
politik ich habe bereits gesagt dass
deutschland einer der wichtigsten
partner russlands die strecken immer die
stärkung der zusammenarbeit zwischen
unseren staaten es entstand der eindruck
dass der bundeskanzler auch pragmatisch
eingespielt ist und auf die zukünftige
zusammenarbeit mit russland eigentlich
in erster linie wirtschaftliche
beziehungen die traditionell sehr
intensiv sind deutschland steht an der
zweiten stelle nach der chinesischen
volksrepublik an unter den partner im
außenhandel trotz der keinesfalls
einfach in situationen hierdurch kann
die biotonne virus und durch volatilität
auf den internationalen märkten
hervorgerufen sind nur
2021 ist der gegenseitige handel um 36
prozent gestiegen und erreichte vor 750
milliarden millionen dollar warum die
deutsche
investitionen in die russische betragen
etwa 21 milliarden im gegenlicht saison
aus russland 10 milliarden insgesamt in
russland sind etwa 4000 unternehmen
tätig mit der beteiligung des deutschen
kapitäns regelmäßig werden treffen
durchgeschlüpft mit den wichtigsten
deutschen unternehmen und diese treffen
werden zweifellos fortgesetzt wir hatten
uns sie sind sehr wichtig was die
meinung unserer deutschen partner angeht
für den aufbau von
entsprechend
biosphäre business atmosphäre auf dem
russischen markt das ist sehr wichtig
für uns denn die unternehmen sei denn
häufig konstruktiver vorschläge zur
verbesserung der gesamten
geschäftsklima in russland viele dieser
vorschläge
berücksichtigen wir und arbeiten sie auf
und integrierenden unser praktisches
leben besonderen platz weil unsere
bilateralen beziehungen basiert die
energie-versorgung bereits in den
siebziger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts haben unser staaten ein
wichtiges projekt onkels gas anstelle
von rühren und sei derzeit die
westlichen und deutschen unternehmen
werbe versorgt russische gast zurzeit
versorgt russland ein drittel die
deutschland mit einem dritten
bedürfnisse es sowas gas angeht das
beträgt 35 prozent bei 1
370 milliarden kubikmeter gas wurde aus
russland geliefert
in anbetracht der börsennotierungen für
gas und dediziert haben wir trotzdem
weiterhin auch diese energieträger
geliefert auf der grundlage der preise
die im rahmen der langfristigen verträge
festgelegt wurden wir führen auch die
klassifizierung und auch die gasleitung
nord stream 2 seit dezember ist diese
gasleitung praktisch vollständig bereits
zu funktionieren dass es eine der
wichtigsten projekte die deutlich die
energiesicherheit auf dem kontinent
festigen würde unter die auch die
aufgaben in der ökologie und in der
wirtschaft
fördern wird ich habe gesagt dass es ein
rein kommerzielles projekt es gibt keine
politische werbung in diesem projekt ich
möchte auch sagen dass wir bereit sind
die gaslieferungen auch durch
bei ihnen weiter so liefen auch nach
2024 nach dem der vertrag ausläuft über
die lieferung über die es natürlich wenn
es die nachfrage vorhanden sein wird
seitens der westlichen partner und wenn
auch die gasleitung und der ukraine dich
nicht
sorgfältig gepflegt wird wir werden auch
die zusammenarbeit in anderen bereichen
der energieteam das bett zum beispiel
die kommerzialisierung und die
anwendung der ökologischen energieträger
wir sprachen heute über wasserstoff
kohlenstoff der dialog in diesen fragen
wird geführt im rahmen der bilateralen
arbeitsgruppe
über die nachhaltige energie wir sind
auch interessiert an der engere
zusammenarbeit mit
der klima
gemeinsam
wir haben für ein monitoring der aus
die beeinflussung der klimaänderung wir
werden auch die
reduzierung der
weiterverbreitung von wasserstoff als
grünes
außerdem haben wir auch interesse an der
weiteren die leute rein endpunkt der
wissenschaften unter virtuellen und
ausbildungs austausch veranstaltung und
hier soll seine rolle spielen
petersburger dialog wir haben natürlich
auch die meinungen ausgetauscht über die
russische initiative und vorschläge an
die usa und auch die nato in bezug auf
die zu verfügt
der russland der langfristigen und
juristisch verpflichtenden sich als
garanten wir sprachen auch über die
wichtigsten forderungen nicht zulassen
der weiteren erweiterung der nato
verzicht auf die unterbringen
warfen schlagkräftigen waffen entlang
der russischen grenze und auch
rückkehr zum zustand von
1997 ist die grundakten russland monate
unterzeichnet worden sind kann die augen
nicht schließen wie die usa und nato
ziemlich frei und zu eigenen gunsten sie
schlüsselprinzipien der gleichen und im
geteilten sicherheit aus legen sie in
den europäischen diese prinzipien haben
nicht nur in sicht den punkt über die
freie wahl der sicherheits wege und auch
den beitritt wird den allianzen
das schließt auch die verpflichtung es
darf nicht die eigene sicherheit auf
kosten der sicherheit der anderen
gefestigt werden und dabei nato verweist
auf die eigene politik der offenen türe
kennen artikel sehen des nato vertrages
ich habe bereits bei früheren
pressekonferenzen darüber gesprochen mit
unseren europäischen partnern artikel
sehen enthält keinesfalls so etwas
geschrieben sie können zwar ein laden zu
mit bestand aber sind nicht verpflichtet
das war
praktisch abschreckung russland sie
jetzt von uns betrachtet als eine
direkte bedrohung unserer sicherheit
dazu dass
die juristischen vereinbarungen die auch
von uns eingebracht worden die antworten
aus der neue sound anderen staaten auf
unsere vorschläge der sicherheit
entsprechen nicht den grundlegenden
russischen forderungen aber in den
antworten sind
vorhanden die wir nicht nur bereit sind
zu besprechen sondern wir haben früher
auch in den vorausgegangenen jahren
diese momente vorgeschlagen in fragen
der europäischen sicherheit
in fragen der
mittelstreckenraketen und
langstreckenraketen diese sind bereits
und wir sind gemeinsamen arbeiten dazu
wir sind auch bereit weiterhin die
verhandlungen zu führen aber alle fragen
müssen komplex betrachtet werden ohne
die wichtigsten vorlege vorschläge zu
ignorieren sie für uns natürlich
priorität liegt natürlich die thematik
der europäischen sicherheit wurde auch
im kontext der situation betrachten im
rahmen der regelung des konflikts
bekanntlich verzichten die kiewer macht
habe auf die einheit und dem minsker
vereinbarungen und der vereinbarung von
und auch verzichten die auf die
erfüllung der vereinbarungen die in
normandie format in berlin und paris
vereinbarten solche zum beispiel die
verfassungsreform nicht die lokale
wahlen rechtliche
momente des sonderstatus freund warst
immer noch sind immer noch nicht die
formel des früheren außenminister der
bundesrepublik deutschland steinmeier
die formel 1 nur der von ihm als
kompromiss vorgeschlagen als er
außenminister war und jetzt
bundespräsident ist leider auch diese
formation immer noch nicht umgesetzt
immer noch werden die
möglichkeiten die wir der herstellung
der
integrität zum wiederherstellung durch
die verhandlungen mit den am bass es
wirken wird wird die diskriminierung der
russen staatliche
bevölkerung verankert wir haben auch
andere fragen besprochen es zum beispiel
wir sprachen über die atomprogramme von
ihrer im rahmen des außenministeriums
passiert die uns im ständigen kontakt in
dieser frage und ich möchte betonen dass
unsere position lösen einander sehr nahe
stehen zum schluss möchte ich mich beim
herrn bundeskanzler wir danken für die
gemeinsame arbeit für die für den
nützlichen und inhaltsreichen doch ich
danke für die aufmerksamkeit
meine damen und herren es ist gut und
wichtig heute hier in moskau zu sein
bedanke mich für den empfang und für das
lange ausführliche gespräch wir haben
wie sie ja schon der darstellung des
präsidenten entnommen haben kein thema
ausgelassen das gegenwärtig in den
beziehungen zwischen unseren beiden
ländern aber auch in den europäischen
beziehungen der internationalen
beziehungen eine rolle spielt das ist
gut so denn natürlich ist es richtig
dass wir tatsächlich miteinander wegen
unsere beiden länder sind historisch und
kulturell eng miteinander verflochten
die beziehungen sind tief und vielfältig
das zeigen beispielsweise die mehr als
90 aktiven städtepartnerschaften und der
regel kultur jugend und
bildungsaustausch
gerade ist das deutschlandjahr in
russland zu ende gegangen etwa 1000
veranstaltungen in mehr als 70 städten
behandelten das ganze themenspektrum
unserer beziehung von kultur über
wissenschaft umwelt und nachhaltigkeit
bis zur diversität
auch unsere wirtschaftsbeziehung haben
nach wie vor großes potenzial das haben
sie eben schon gehört insbesondere war
zentralen zukunftsthemen wie der
dekarbonisierung bei den erneuerbaren
energien bei wasserstoff und der
digitalisierung
unsere verantwortung für das
menschheitsthema klimawandel können wir
nur gerecht werden wenn wir das
gemeinsam angehen und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass auch in den beziehungen
zwischen deutschland und russland das
für die zukunft von zentraler bedeutung
bleibt energie wird heute auch geliefert
aber die frage ist wie wir es
hinbekommen dass das auch gelingen kann
in einer industriellen welt die co2
neutral ist als notwendig ist wenn wir
auf diesem planeten gut leben können
wollen ein unverzichtbarer pfeiler
unserer beziehung ist er zwischen
gesellschaftlicher dialog der viel zu
verständigen und zur aussöhnung zwischen
unseren völkern nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg beigetragen hat diese
entwicklung gilt es weiter zu fördern
darum haben wir heute auch schon über
dem petersburger dialog gesprochen er
steht seit jahren für die
deutsch-russische verständigung ist
gerade jetzt wichtiger denn je ich habe
daher meine hoffnung zum ausdruck
gebracht dass bei weiteren hochrangigen
gesprächen in nächster zeit eine lösung
für die aktuelle blockade erreicht
werden kann und wir brauchen einen raum
für offenen und ehrlichen dialog bei dem
alle themen besprochen werden können und
auch alle sich in diese debatte
einbringen können die das wollen und die
dazu gehören mit sorge sehen wir wie die
räume für die zivilgesellschaft
schwieriger werden das gilt für uns
insbesondere im hinblick auf solche
partner mit denen wir lange und wichtig
zusammengearbeitet haben ich will hier
die gruppe memorial nennen das ist in
deutschland auf großes unverständnis
gewonnen stoßen dass die ihre tätigkeit
nun nicht fortsetzen kann ausgerechnet
eine organisation die er unter anderem
einen zentralen beitrag zur aufklärung
des schicksals der sowjetischen
zwangsarbeiter im nazi deutschland
geleistet hat wir hoffen dass dort eine
gute perspektive möglich ist ich habe in
unseren gesprächen auch die erwartung
geäußert dass die deutsche welle in
russland weiter journalistisch tätig
sein kann wie schon gesagt ein breites
themenspektrum von bilateralen interesse
und wir haben dabei auch die kritischen
fragen nicht vermieden das zeichnet
solche gespräche aus und ist wichtig
mein besuch heute gesteht aber natürlich
ganz wesentlich im zeichen der krise der
wohl schwersten bedrohlichsten krise die
wir seit sehr langer zeit in europa
jetzt erleben die
militärischen truppen zusammenstellung
und aktivitäten russlands an der
ukrainischen grenze
haben einen breiten raum in unseren
gesprächen eingenommen wie auch
natürlich die fragen nach den
sicherheitsgarantien die russland
formuliert hat ich habe dabei unsere
einschätzung meiner einschätzung der
sicherheitslage erläutert und wie wir
unsere europäischen partner diese
entwicklung bewerten aber auch natürlich
den truppenaufmarsch
als bedrohung empfinden in diesem
zusammenhang kann man gar nicht genug
betonen dass wir sehr besorgt sind was
wohl aus dem 100.000 soldaten und ihren
aktivitäten in nächster zeit werden wird
wir können keinen vernünftigen grund für
diese truppen zusammenstellung erkennen
deshalb ist die deeskalation dringend
geboten und das ist in dieser an
gespendeten und schwierigen situation
wichtig damit es keinen krieg in europa
gibt
präsident putin hat mir in unserem
gespräch von den gestrigen beratungen
mit seinem außenminister und dem
verteidigungsminister berichtet hat eben
davon auch erneut gesprochen stimme
ausdrücklich zu die diplomatischen
möglichkeiten sind bei weitem nicht
ausgeschöpft jetzt muss es darum gehen
entschlossen und mutig an einer
friedlichen auflösung dieser krise zu
arbeiten
dass wir jetzt hören dass einzelne
truppen abgezogen werden ist jedenfalls
ein gutes zeichen wir hoffen dass da
noch welche folgen wir sind bereit
gemeinsam mit allen partnern und
verbündeten in der eu und der nato und
russland über ganz konkrete schritte zur
verbesserung der gegenseitigen oder noch
besser der gemeinsamen sicherheit zu
unternehmen dazu hat die nato bereits zu
konkreten thematischen gespräch im
nato-russland-rat eingeladen dazu sind
die usa in den bilateralen gesprächen
mit russland bereit und im rahmen auch
der osze hat der polnische vorsitz einen
neuen hochrangigen dialog prozess
initiiert
dieser dialog wird im geist der
gegenseitigkeit und anerkennung der
gesamtheit von prinzipien und
verpflichtungen erfolgen wie wir sie
alle gemeinsam in der osze vereinbart
haben dazu gehören
die unverletzlichkeit der grenzen europa
die souveränität und territoriale
unversehrtheit aller staaten auch der
ukraine und die sind für uns und
verhandelbar
ein dringender wunsch lassen sie uns
diese dinge im wege des dialogs weiter
wir reden wir dürfen nicht in einer
sackgasse enden die wäre ein unglück für
uns alle
für die bundesregierung ist klar dass
eine weitere militärische aggression
gegen die ukraine
schwerwiegende politische
wirtschaftliche und strategische
konsequenzen zur folge hätte mein
eindruck ist dass wissen alle ganz genau
eine solche eskalation gilt es deshalb
jetzt mit aller kraft und
entschlossenheit und aller klugheit zu
vermeiden die suche nach diplomatischen
lösungen sind ein zentraler grund meiner
reise nach kiew gestern und nun nach
moskau
präsident putin und ich sind uns einig
dass das normandie format neben den
gesprächen zwischen den usa und russland
im nato-russland-rat und der osze ein
weiteres wichtiges format zur beilegung
des konflikts darstellt hier brauchen
wir bewegung und natürlich auch
fortschritt
deshalb ist es gut dass präsident
seelands gestern fest zugesagt hat
dass der trilateralen kontaktgruppe die
im rahmen des metzger prozess
festgesetzt worden ist und der alle
beteiligten zusammen kommen in kürze
alle drei vorgesehenen gesetzestexte zum
status der ost ukraine zur
verfassungsänderung und zur
wahlvorbereitung vorliegen werden das
ist ein guter fortschritt und daran gilt
es anzuknüpfen
ich habe den präsidenten am und hat
seine verhandlung
einem entsprechenden konstruktiven
wandert aus zu gestalten so dass wir
dort fortschritte erreichen kann
zum abschluss auch noch mal dies für uns
deutsche aber auch für alle europäer ist
klar dass nachhaltige sicherheit nicht
gegen russland und nur mist russland
erreicht werden kann darüber sind wir
uns aber auch alle einig in der nato und
in der europäischen union und deshalb
müsste es möglich sein eine lösung zu
finden so schwierig und ernst die
derzeitige lage auch scheint ich weigere
mich sie als aussichtslos zu beschreiben
von allen ist jetzt mutiges und
verantwortungsbewusstes handeln gefragt
das will ich doch sagen für meine
generation ist krieg in europa und
denkbar geworden und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass das so bleibt es ist unsere
verdammte pflicht und aufgabe als staats
und regierungschefs zu verhindern dass
es in europa zu einer kriegerischen
eskalation kommt
passieren sagen jetzt natürlich ganz
schön unter druck
des präsidenten russlands und des
bundeskanzlers deutschlands die
journalisten haben die möglichkeit die
fragen zu stellen nach unserer tradition
die erste frage geht an michael hübner
von der deutschen welle
präsident putin sie haben gleichzeitig
signalisiert dass sie dem dialog sehen
und haben gleichzeitig kritik hat der
bundeskanzler nicht genug mitgebracht
besonders von präsident seelands wie mit
diesem zusicherungen und die frage die
sich alle europäer stellen ist trotz
dieser enge beziehung zu russland
wird es nochmal krieg geben in europa
schließen sie jetzt im augenblick krieg
aus wo laut euro in jork und herr
bundeskanzler an sie die frage wie
schätzen sie denn jetzt die lage nach
diesem gespräch ein
gab es fortschritte so wie sie sich das
vorgestellt haben und was muss der
nächste schritt sein
was den krieg in europa angeht herr
bundeskanzler hat jetzt gerade gesagt
dass menschen seiner generation und ich
gehöre zu dieser generation können sich
kaum vorstellen ein krieg in europa
welche auch immer und das wurde
natürlich gesagt in bezug auf die
situation in der ukraine aber wir waren
doch mit ihnen zeugen des krieges in
nord eben von block nato entfesselt
gegen
eine große militärische
kooperation mit raketen und pumpen
beobachte man üben über einen der hand
städte in europa belgrad wir haben das
jahr erlebt ohne sanktionen der
sicherheitsrate uno
das ist ein schlechtes beispiel
aber was hat sowas gegeben das ist das
erste
in bezug auf wir das wollen oder nicht
natürlich nicht eben gerade deshalb
haben wir den vorschlag eingebracht über
den verhandlungsprozess in deren
ergebnis die vereinbarung stehen soll
über die sicherung der gleichen
sicherheit aller einschließlich auf
unseres landes leider und das haben wir
schon besprochen einen gegenständliche
konstruktiven vorschlag auf unser unsere
position haben wir nicht bekommen
dennoch gehen wir davon aus dass selbst
in diesen dokumenten die uns
überleitet wurden aus nato und aus
washington auch bestimmte elemente
enthalten sind die wir besprechen können
aber hier sind bereit das zu tun
zusammen mit allen grundlegenden fragen
sie für uns die erste
rolle spielen und wir rechnen damit dass
sagte ich heute der bundeskader salopp
ebenso verlaufen wird und abhängig davon
wie dieser dialog sich entwickelt wird
auch die situation in allen anderen
bereichen immer sich entwickeln die sie
und uns beunruhigt und uns beunruhigt
das genauso wie sie ich versichere ich
glaube dass wir jetzt eine situation
haben das drauf ankommt alle
möglichkeiten zu nutzen keinen faden
ungenutzt zu lassen und dafür zu sorgen
dass wir eine friedliche entwicklung
möglich machen
das ist der grund warum mich gerichtet
habe das für den winzer prozess jetzt
wichtige voraussetzungen auch
angekündigt sind mit den entsprechenden
gesetzesvorhaben aus meiner sicht muss
das auch dazu beitragen dass jetzt die
gespräche in der trilateralen
kontaktgruppe aufgenommen werden können
über diese vorschläge und dass das dann
auch ein ausgangspunkt ist für eine
friedliche lösung der situation in der
ukraine
zwischen dem mit dem don was und mit der
ukrainischen regierung
was für mich wichtig ist dass die
gespräche dort stattfinden in dieser
trilateralen kontaktgruppe das ist das
was immens miteinander vereinbart worden
ist und darauf arbeiten wir hin dass das
möglich wird die gerne noch mal sagen
dass ich glaube dass es im jugoslawien
eine etwas andere situation gab es gab
die gefahr eines
völkermordes und das musste verhindert
werden ich bin froh dass wir
mittlerweile eine friedliche entwicklung
haben und dass die länder des balkans
alle eine eigene perspektive jeweils in
richtung der europäischen union gefunden
haben aus sich heraus ich glaube dass es
ein gutes zeichen
was soll ich erlaube mir noch
hinzuzufügen dass das was in den basiert
stattfindet das ist eben die genozide
die agentur maria geb ich habe eine
große frage die viele bereiche
sind gerade aus kiew zurück gekommen sie
trafen sich mit dem präsidenten
was meinen sie wird oder will kiew die
minsker vereinbarungen erfüllen in der
art wie sie abgeschlossen wurde und
welche perspektiven der friedlichen
regelung und häppchen heute morgen kamen
die neuigkeiten über teilweisen abzug
der truppen gekommen und sogleich die
neuigkeiten aus der stadt duma
abgeordneten haben sich an sie gewandert
die
bonner republik
anzuerkennen nicht so genannten
republiken und dann muss ich auch beide
für ihre fragen wie sie das schicksal
von nord stream 2 besteht die
möglichkeit
und noch eine frage an herrn putin ich
bitte um entschuldigung
ihr alter bekannter herr schröder
zu einem der kandidaten zum direktorin
rat folgt und danach wurde er stark
kritisiert in europa was können sie dazu
sagen danke
das erste was war das also die
abstimmung könnte
staatsduma es wurde mir jetzt gerade
mitgeteilt vor der pressekonferenz
und auch teilweise absurd truppen aus
den
regionen unserer manöver was soll ich
dazu sagen was die exekutive angeht auch
dann politisch militärischen führung da
kann man nicht kommentieren es wurde die
entscheidung getroffen aber teilweise
absurd getroffen und die abstimmung in
der stadt lohmar ist mehr oder weniger
damit verbunden denn sie abgeordneten
des parlaments wie in jedem land auch in
russland richten sich nach der
öffentlichen meinung nach der meinung
der wähler und sie verspüren dieser
meinung ganz deutlich und in dieser
hinsicht ganz offensichtlich die
überwiegende mehrheit der menschen
sind
unterstützen die einwohner von den bass
und sie hoffen dass die situation dort
grundlegend sich ändern wird natürlich
zum besten für die zum essen ich weiß es
gab zwei über hersteller das eine
projekt wurde von dieser rasse
einheitliches russland das bekannt die
große mehrheit und das zweite projekt
das ist ein viel viel
ausgedruckt eine direkte
anwendung an den präsidenten mit der
aufforderung zur anerkennung dieser
sogenannten republiken und das war eine
offene abstimmung ohne parteidisziplin
und die mehrheit der abgeordneten haben
die resolution und unterstützt praktisch
von der oppositionellen partei von der
kommunistischen partei der russischen
föderation
ich würde davon ausgehen dass wir alles
unternehmen
müssen um das problem rasch zu lösen
aber wir müssen das tun wir
herr bundeskanzler gesagt hat in erster
linie wir müssen aus der nicht zuende
umgesetzten möglichkeiten der minsker
vereinbarungen tun und wir müssen und
wir rechnen fest damit dass unser
partner hinter dem ozean und auch in
europa in vor allem bundesrepublik
deutschland und frankreich ein sprecher
entsprechend die kiewer regierung
beeinflussen werden und die lösung
gefunden wird jetzt in bezug auf herrn
schröder und nord stream 2 wissen sie
ich habe heute dass ein bundeskanzler
anfang des jahres 2000 haben wir mit der
ukraine vereinbart und damals stand herr
kretschmann an der spitze der ukraine
und von der deutschen seite war der
kanzler schröder und russland ich für
ihr ergebene diener und wir haben eine
vereinbarung unterzeichnet über die
schaffung eines internationalen und sich
unter beteiligung russland ukraine und
deutschland möglicherweise auch andere
europäischen partner die dieses projekt
zu verwalten würde nicht einkaufen nicht
in besitz übernehmen das würde auch im
besitz der ukrainischen stadt was
bleiben aber unter verwaltungsstellen
und tee oder es macht und das
weiterentwickeln entsprechendes geld
investieren um die technische
entwicklung zu unterhalten und dann die
wahl sowie spätere
regierung in der person von herrn
verweigert dass ich weiter das
umzusetzen und dann entstand die frage
über die gewährleistung der sicherheit
liefe rungen noch durch und deshalb
hatte er schröder die den bau von mosley
mainz unterstützt bitkom durch
prävention von 50 milliarden kubikmeter
gas über diese strecke und dieses gas
konnte nach langfristigen verträgen er
im nach deutschland die wie gesagt
also und dass sie
liegen um das siebenfache unter dem
preis in europa jetzt
und der deutsche verbraucher sowohl in
der industrie als auch die haushalte
bekommen das gas aus russland 5 malta
sollen die deutschen bürger ihr
portemonnaie aufmachen und drei schauen
und sagen ob er bereit ist drei- bis
viermal mehr bezahlen für energieträger
für
gas wenn er das nicht will dann soll er
sich bedanken eben beim herrn schröder
denn das ist das ergebnis seiner arbeit
diese positive was seine präsenz an der
verwaltungs organen von grasbrunn angeht
dann heute beunruhigt viele
reguläre
lieferungen von
russischen energie ressourcen nach
europa weiter fortgesetzt werden und
auch nach deutschland im einzelnen ich
glaube wenn diese entscheidung getroffen
wird darüber dass herr schröder mitglied
des direktoriums von gazprom sein wird
dann eben zum zwecke der kontrolle
seitens eines unabhängigen experten und
herr schröder ist ganz eindeutig ein
unabhängiger experte ein anständiger
mann von denen wir großen respekt haben
und er natürlich
vorsicht die aufgabe stellt die
interessen des eigenen landes umzusetzen
der bundesrepublik deutschland also die
bundesrepublik deutschland und ihre
bewährten eine person erhaben in seine
person die sowohl die entscheidungen
beeinflussen kann und auch natürlich
direkt von gazprom und die tiefe
information bekommt ich bin immer das
kann doch nur nutzen unsere zusammen man
könnte sich eigentlich nur darüber
freuen dass soweit kommt oder nicht ich
glaube die wahlen finden irgendwann im
juni statt aber das ist die frage von
gazprom selbst und der unabhängige
erstarken einschließlich herren schröder
jetzt wasser aus dem 2
das verbleib im rat der direktorin von
gastronomie selbstverständlich denn er
beschäftigte sich mit der umsetzung von
nord stream ein und austria ist ja mit
dem 2 an der finanzierung beteiligen
sich fünf deutsche
unternehmen einschließlich zwei große
deutsche energieunternehmen dieser
schlossen 2 ist fertig und bereits zur
industriellen nutzung seit
oktober letzten jahres und das hängt
aber von dem regulierer deutschen der
endgültige entscheidung über die
lieferungen über die nos im 2
entscheiden muss was wäre es
zunächst war die frage nach dem minsker
vereinbarung an die müssen sich alle
halten das gilt für die regierung der
ukraine das gilt selbstverständlich für
russland für deutschland und frankreich
die beteiligt sind an den politischen
prozess der dazu gehört und deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass alle ihren beitrag
leisten bei einem beitrag ist das jetzt
all die gesetzentwürfe zur verfügung
stehen werden die notwendig sind um
darüber zu reden wie die drei großen
aufgaben gelöst werden die ich bereits
im eingang statement erwähnt habe und
die eben etwas zu tun haben mit dem
speziellen stadt tut mit den wahlen mit
der steinmeier formel und
selbstverständlich mit dem
verfassungsfragen alles das wird
vorliegen und dann wird in dem
trilateralen format zwischen der ukraine
russland und der oecd und den weiteren
beteiligten darüber zu sprechen sein das
ist das was vereinbart ist und dieser
prozess sollte von allen unterstützt
werden und von niemandem aufgehalten
werden jeder leicht natürlich dazu die
dinge zu seinen gunsten auszulegen aber
in wahrheit steht alles aufgeschrieben
und mein wunsch ist dass alle sich an
ruck geben und jetzt das schon einmal
vereinbarte in eine verständigung über
setzen dass es noch viel zu diskutieren
gibt aber wo der nächste schritt jetzt
mal erfolgen soll das ist jedenfalls
mein wunsch und die voraussetzungen sind
dafür da wenn alle sich einen ruck geben
kann es auch klappen aber nur dann
selbstverständlich würde
das bedeuten die meistens gar
vereinbarung zu missachten wenn die
resolution die das parlament heute
getroffen hat realität würde ich glaube
das wissen auch alle beteiligten deshalb
geht es nicht um diese resolution die
würde dagegen sprechen dann wäre der
prozess abgebrochen und beendet das wäre
eine politische katastrophe sondern das
ginge nur wenn dann gewissermaßen alle
wieder zurückkehren zu dieser
vereinbarung hat der see eingangs
gefragt haben und er hat im klare
kriterien
was
[Musik]
nach dem 2 betrifft
werde ich die privat wirtschaftlichen
aktivitäten eines früheren politikers
nicht weiter kommentieren er spricht
nicht für die bundesrepublik deutschland
sondern für sich
was die pipeline selber betrifft
wir sind alle was los ist
wir haben uns verpflichtet
sicherzustellen dass der gastransit in
europa funktioniert über die ukraine
über belarus und wollen mit strippen 1
insgesamt
entsprechend der vereinbarung die wir
haben und dafür werden wir auch sorge
tragen wir wollen sicherstellen dass wir
eine friedliche entwicklung in europa
zustande bekommen dass es nicht zu einer
militärischen konfrontation in der
ukraine kommt wenn es doch so ist dann
wird es weitreichende konsequenzen haben
darüber sind sich auch alle klar wir
jedenfalls wissen was dann zu tun ist
und mein eindruck ist dass das auch alle
anderen ganz genau wissen die verstehen
das los ist und
verstehen auch die politischen
realitäten in denen wir uns dann bewegen
deshalb gibt es ja jetzt darum dass wir
alles dafür tun exakt diese situation zu
vermeiden indem wir auf eine friedliche
entwicklung setzen und als wahre
politische führer erweisen die den
beitrag dazu leisten dass nicht nur
jeder mit dem finger auf den anderen
zeigt sondern jeder seinen beitrag
leistet dazu dass der friede bewahrt
werden kann das ist die aufgabe die wir
haben
als nächstes michael fischer von dpa
[Musik]
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler zuerst an
sie eine frage sie haben eben schon
angesprochen dass sie
schwierige themen in den deutsch
russischen beziehungen in ihrem gespräch
mit präsident hin angesprochen haben sie
haben memorial genannt sie haben die
deutsche welle genannt es gibt ja noch
andere themen zum beispiel den vielen
nachteilen jeder hat heute ein prozess
begonnen es gibt die
medizinischen zwangs tests für ausländer
es gibt die russischen cyberattacken auf
deutschland haben sie auch das
angesprochen auf welche resonanz sind
sie da gestoßen bei präsident putin und
wie würden sie den zustand der deutsch
russischen beziehungen insgesamt
beschreiben und dann sicher präsident
putin die nachfrage noch mal zudem zu
den ersten schritten des truppenabzugs
heute wie wird das in den nächsten tagen
und wochen weitergehen werden weitere
truppen abgezogen
können sie einen angriff auf die ukraine
heute ausschließen und eine frage zu
zu der zum nato-beitritt der ukraine
sina die bundeskanzler scholz und auch
andere staats und regierungschefs der
nato sind ja nicht bereit eine garantie
dafür abzugeben dass die ukraine nicht
in die nato aufgenommen worden ist
können sie sich aber vielleicht ein
moratorium vorstellen denn es wird ja
jetzt gesagt von nato seite dass ein
solcher beitritt in den nächsten jahren
vielleicht sogar jahrzehnten
unrealistisch ist
wir haben viele themen angesprochen ich
habe über einige berichtet was dann
navalny betrifft ist meine haltung sind
klar und rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen
ist seine verurteilung nicht vereinbar
und diese position habe ich schon bei
vielen gelegenheiten zum ausdruck
gebracht
ja ich hab so verstanden dass unser
gast mir die möglichkeit gegeben hat
ihre frage zu beantworten
erst in bezug auf darauf wie russland
weiter
zitiert nach dem plan
voraus
der realen situation an ort und stelle
wer kann jetzt die frage beantworten wie
die reale situation sich gestalten wird
bis jetzt keiner das hängt nicht nur von
uns ab aber wir streben an dass wir uns
vereinbaren mit unseren partner über die
fragen die von uns gestellt wurden damit
sie gelöst werden auf diplomatischen
wege welche fragen das sind sind sehr
gut zum in bezug auf die sicherung der
sicherheit russlands nicht in ost
erweiterung der nato nicht
die die
rückführung der struktur der nato 29 97
und nicht unterbringen in der nähe
unserer grenze der kampf schlag
militärischen kräfte wir sind bereit
auch über andere fragen zu sprechen die
in der von uns erhalten
antwort
enthalten sind aber in dem komplex was
wir uns erstrangig ist jetzt
bezug auf
der zweite teil ihrer frage ich habe
irgendwas hier gekritzelt und
es ging es ging um den truppenabzug von
der ukrainischen grenze und um die nato
erweiterung jetzt
in bezug auf truppenabzug
habe ich schon gesagt ich bin der
meinung da habe ich schon beantwortet
das über die erweiterung der nato sie
haben einen sehr guten satz formuliert
es wird gesprochen dass in den nächsten
jahren ukraine nicht sonata gehören wird
was heißt es es wird gemunkelt
angesprochen wir müssen doch verstehen
was bedeutet das es wird gemunkelt in
der zwischenstaatlichen beziehungen seit
30 jahren wird uns gesagt dass es
keine erweiterung stattfinde und keine
zentimeter und jetzt sehen wir die
infrastruktur der natur direkt vor
unserem haus mehr noch es wird
gesprochen dass die ukraine nato
beitritt es wird gemunkelt dass das
nicht morgen wird aber dann übermorgen
und was ändert das für uns in der
historischen
sichtweise praktisch gar nichts wir
hören
dass die ukraine nicht bereit ist jetzt
der nato beizutreten erkennen und sofort
wird gesagt dass morgen die ukraine
nicht aufgenommen wird sondern es wird
die ukraine erst dann aufgenommen wenn
sie vorbereitet sein wird aber für uns
kann es ja schon zu spät sein deshalb
wollen wir jetzt diese frage lösen also
unmittelbar jetzt in der nächsten zeit
im zuge des verhandlungsprozesses mit
friedlichen mitteln davon gehen wir aus
und wir hoffen sehr darauf dass unsere
sorgen von unseren partner gehört werden
und auch ernst genommen werden
martin
einen schönen guten tag ich möchte den
erste frage an wladimir putin gestern
beim treffen mit herrn prof haben sie
die antwort über die grenze hier an
russland und sie haben waren einig dass
die perspektiven der
vereinbarungen sozusagen vorhanden sind
ist bedeutet das dass jetzt unsere
langwierige verhandlungen bevorstehen
und wenn man berücksichtigt dass usa
unterdessen manche sachen nicht
annehmen und fragen jetzt
ich möchte auch eine frage ob es möglich
ist
eine konstruktive
konstruktive regelung der frage
vielleicht gemeinsam geschaffen dass wir
weiter bei uns und die deutsche welle
hier weiter jetzt in bezug auf die
deutsche welle wurde gefragt wir haben
in der tat darüber heute mit dem
bundeskanzler besprochen sowohl die
frage der deutschen welle in russland
und auch die arbeit von
[Musik]
russia today sie in der bundesrepublik
deutschland ich möchte jetzt nicht ins
detail gehen er und die situation nicht
so vor komplizieren aber wir haben
vereinbart dass wir uns gedanken machen
werden die wir diese probleme lösen
können das ist das erste und das zweite
jetzt
über die
oder den möglichen langwierigen
charakter der verhandlungen die in
dieser gasse führen werden eben gerade
aus diesem grund habe ich gestern mit
dem außenminister und mit meinen
kollegen aus den militärischen
ministerien darüber nachgedacht haben
natürlich wir haben diese sorge es
besteht darin dass wir die befürchtung
haben dass der verhandlungsprozess
über die von uns
vorgeschlagenen wesen blicken wir uns
fragen im bereich der sicherheit dass
dieser prozess von unserer partner und
begründet in die länge gezogen werden
kann und dass im zuge dieses
verhandlungsprozess mehr oder wenige die
entscheidung getroffen werden die unsere
situation verschlechtern werden uns war
sehr ernst hat verschlechtern so wie das
bis jetzt geschehen war
verlaufen vielen vielen vorausgegangenen
jahren das ist natürlich das was jetzt
in unserem blickfeld liegt was wir
verstehen und das was wir zweifellos
erörtern werden mit unseren partnern und
das was wir nicht zulassen werden
zunächst mal die frage
rt die sie gestellt haben das ist ein
rechtsstaatliches verfahren dem grün
anträge gestellt werden auch solche die
bisher nicht gestellt wurden und die
werden dann ordnungsgemäß von den
zuständigen behörden bearbeitet
das geschieht nach gesetzen die bereits
existieren und auf die sich jeder
gleichmäßig berufen kann darauf können
sich alle verlassen aber es gibt ein
rechtsstaatliches verfahren und da
müssen die voraussetzungen gewünschten
ich will noch etwas sagen zu der
situation der gespräche
die position sind unterschiedlich dass
es klar geworden darum haben wir uns
einander unterhalten das ist auch
richtig aber es ist immerhin so dass
mittlerweile gesprochen wird und ich
finde richtig dass die nato und die
europäische union auf die briefe
russlands geantwortet haben und es ist
ein gutes zeichen dass russland zwar
nicht einverstanden ist mit der antwort
aber sagt da sind ein paar gute dinge
drin und umgekehrt ist es so dass mit
den vorstellungen die russland
formuliert hat die nato die eu auch wir
nicht einverstanden sind aber finden da
sind ein paar punkte drin über die es
nun miteinander zu reden und das was
jetzt notwendig ist damit es nicht zu
einer gefährlichen situation in europa
chance die wir alle vermeiden müssen ist
dass jeder weiß das ist schon ganz viel
kleine ansätze für gespräche und dass
man sie dann auch real führen muss um
all die fragen die wichtig sind das
fängt an bei der frage der lösung dieser
problematik der ukraine mit dem minsker
vereinbarung und den prozess der dazu
vereinbart ist an dem sich alle präzise
halten müssen und mit innerem willen auf
einen erfolg miteinander sprechen müssen
das gilt auch für die unterschiedlichen
positionen zur frage der
nato-osterweiterung
da ist ja die etwas eigenwillige
situation dass die gar nicht ansteht
besteht nicht auf der tagesordnung jeder
weiß es ganz genau
das ist kein thema das uns
wahrscheinlich in unseren ämtern
begegnen wird wieder
solange wir sie ausüben ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie lange der präsident vor hatte
im amt zu sein da war ich ebenfalls ab
dieses gefühl das könnte länger dauern
aber nicht ewig und insofern werden wir
deshalb doch die aufgabe haben jetzt aus
dieser diesem punkt etwas zu machen dass
man miteinander zu einer politischen
verständigen kann ohne dass irgendjemand
seine grundsätze seine prinzipien dabei
aufgeben muss das ist politische führung
und das ist verantwortung die wir
gegenüber unseren ländern die wir
regieren und dem internationalen frieden
und der zusammenarbeit in europa haben
und darum gibt es dann auch wenn wir
insgesamt über die sprechen fragen
sprechen die wichtig sind für sicherheit
und zusammenarbeit in europa über fragen
von transparenz und über fragen von
rüstungskontrolle der wunsch ist von
allen formuliert die nato hat das
positiv beantwortet dann auch anders als
gewünscht aber immerhin da ist ein
ausgangspunkt wir sollten die
ausgangspunkte nutzen um unsere
verantwortung gerecht zu werden
was die mobile e-plus gewinnzusage schön
kollegen die pressekonferenz ist zu ende
also das war sie die pressekonferenz aus
moskau mit bundeskanzler olaf scholz und
dem russischen präsidenten wladimir
putin
wir gehen gleich weiter zu unserem
experten professor jäger denn darüber
müssen wir sprechen es fing ja erst so
habe ich es zumindest gehört sehr
einvernehmlich an man hat gemeinsam
eigentlich ganz gut und erfolgreich
versucht auch das thema north stream so
er so ein bisschen zu umschiffen aber
hinterher indem frage teil da kam doch
einige empfindlichkeiten hoch was haben
sie da am lautesten gehört
nun lassen sie mich mit einer
kleinigkeit beginnen olaf scholz hat
nord stream zwei gesagt das wird sicher
aus dieser pressekonferenz mitgenommen
werden und deswegen wollte ich das an
den anfang stellen dann ist es richtig
dass beide damit begonnen haben ganz
andere felder der zusammenarbeit die
energiebeziehungen die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen kulturelle
beziehungen den zwischen
gesellschaftlichen dialog zu besprechen
der petersberger dialog ist mehrfach
angesprochen worden und das zeigt dass
hier eben das weite feld der bilateralen
beziehungen die momentan ja nicht
wirklich gut sind besprochen wurde und
möglicherweise das ein oder andere
projekt dabei auch besprochen wurde das
jetzt angeschoben werden kann und dann
war klar dass es hinausläuft auf die
fragen die jetzt wieder elefant in jedem
raum stehen wenn europäische russische
amerikanische
verantwortliche miteinander sprechen und
da sind konkret die krise um die ukraine
auf der einen seite und die russischen
forderungen nach einer neuordnung
europas in sicherheitspolitischer
hinsicht auf der anderen seite und da
sind die unterschiedlichen positionen
deutlich geworden und der bundeskanzler
hat das am ende in einer aufzählung
zusammen geführt in dem er sagte es
ginge darum eine politische
einigung zu finden bei der beide seiten
nicht ihre prinzipien aufgeben müssten
das ist das sozusagen
die aufgabe die jetzt ansteht und über
die man sehen muss wie man in eine
möglichkeit kommt hier die grundlegende
sicherheitspolitische frage die russland
gestellt hat zu beantworten was die
ukraine angeht um darauf noch einzugehen
da wurde es konkreter das wurde gestern
ja schon gesagt dass die ukraine jetzt
die gesetze zur verfügung stellen wird
die notwendig sind um in dem
umstrittenen gebiet dann wahlen
durchzuführen autonomiestatus festlegen
zu können und da wird auch noch viel zu
besprechen sein denn die ukrainische
regierung die russische regierung haben
völlig unterschiedliche vorstellungen
welche autorität dann dort
angesiedelt sein wird aber immerhin geht
das jetzt auf den weg und das sind
glaube ich die zwei großen
ergebnisse die bundeskanzler schulz aus
diesen gesprächen mitnehmen kann
bleiben wir mal bei der nato da hat ja
nun wladimir putin doch sehr deutlich
gesagt dass er jetzt und nicht erst in
sehr ferner zukunft wenn sowie kanzler
sagte vielleicht beide gar nicht mehr im
amt sein würden er da gerne eine lösung
oder ein 1 1 einen standpunkt einen
klaren standpunkt von nato seite haben
möchte was einen möglichen beitritt der
ukraine angeht olaf scholz hat sich dann
ein wenig zurückgezogen und gesagt was
sie eben auch erwähnten man müsse da
eine lösung finden wobei die ihr gesicht
wahren können es gab ja eine frage eines
deutschen journalisten auch nach einem
möglichen moratorium also eine das wäre
ja eine möglichkeit
wobei die ihr gesicht wahren könnten ist
aber niemand so wirklich darauf
eingegangen warum nicht
doch präsident putin hat dass die frage
genommen und hat sich sozusagen
geschickt über die schulter geworfen und
gesagt das ist genau das problem was
wollen wir mit einem moratorium wo es
dann heißt für ein paar jahre wird die
ukraine nicht aufgenommen das muss
grundlegend geregelt werden die
moratoriums idee ist ja länger im
gespräch ich glaube das erste mal kamen
sie auf so mit dem wert von 25 jahre
dass das ist ja etwas was man dann in
die zukunft verschieben kann und wer
weiß wie dann die bedingungen sind dass
russland jetzt auf einer glasklaren
schriftlichen vereinbarung besteht ist
der ausgangspunkt der verhandlung und
ich kann mir momentan auch noch nicht
wirklich vorstellen wie eine politische
verständigung aussieht die diese
widerstreitenden prinzipien beider
bestehen lässt aber da wird man noch mal
drüber nachdenken müssen und am ende
kann man vielleicht ein paket packen
indem noch viel mehr drin ist etwa die
von bundeskanzler scholz angesprochenen
punkte von transparenz und
rüstungskontrolle bei der ja die
bereitschaft der nato staaten jetzt
gegeben sein könnte hier wieder in
intensivere gespräche jetzt zu treten
wenn auch russland genau diese fragen
bereit ist zu besprechen da ist sind als
aber das problem dass bei der einen oder
anderen frage eben der dritte im bund
china noch mit angesprochen es wenn es
etwa um mittelstreckenraketen geht
deswegen ist es ja letztlich gescheitert
aber das wird man jetzt sehen müssen ob
man ein paket macht in denen mit dem wir
sozusagen in einzelfällen einzelnen
nicht zufrieden sein können aber mit der
paketlösung möglicherweise dann leben
können
wenn ich das noch anführen darf ein
wichtiger satz den bundeskanzler scholz
gesagt hat wenn es zum krieg käme das
wäre zitat ein unglück für uns alle